-How are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I am well, I am well.
I am well.
-Very happy that you found time
in what I assume
is an incredibly busy schedule
to be here with us.
-I'm glad to be with you.
-It's a question I'm gonna
try to ask everyone who is here,
who is trying to do
what you're doing.
A lot of Senators
are running for president,
a lot of your colleagues,
where you still work.
You have to go
to work with them.
-Yes.
-Is it awkward...
[ Laughter ]
...when you see each other?
-You know, no, it's actually --
I mean, so far so good.
-Uh-huh.
-I think that all of us have
a lot of respect for each other,
and many of us
have worked together,
certainly since I've been there
the last two years.
And so, so far so good.
-All right.
Well, I'm glad to hear that.
I hope it doesn't
end in fisticuffs.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You were a district attorney,
both in San Francisco
and for the State of California,
so you have a prosecutorial
background which, I think,
a lot of people have noticed
in committee hearings.
You are very good
at asking questions.
-Yeah.
-Do you feel like
these questions, at this point,
and the kind of questions
that the Trump administration
is being asked now
are making
the President nervous?
Or is this just how he is?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, here's the thing, Seth.
When I'm there
asking those questions,
it is because I believe the
American people want the truth.
And sometimes you have to
extract the truth from people.
And so, you know, but we gotta
go where we have to go
to get at what's going on,
what has happened.
And that's how I think
of my role in those hearings.
-I know you have to walk
sort of a sensitive line here,
but you're on the
Senate Intelligence Committee,
so you've seen things
that maybe aren't public.
And we're in a situation now
where we have a Mueller report
that's out but not public.
-Right.
-We have a letter
from Attorney General Barr.
Does it square,
what the four-page letter
Barr put out with what you know?
-Well, put aside what I know.
I think what
the American public knows
is that Bob Mueller was engaged
with an incredible team
for two years
in an investigation.
And the Attorney General
produced a four-page document
in two days.
And so, I think everyone
is smart enough to know
how could he possibly have
summarized two years worth
of around-the-clock
investigations
in two days
into just four pages?
And for that reason,
I think we all know
we need to have
full transparency.
The American public
deserves to see and know
what that investigation
involves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will say -- and this is a --
this is nonpartisan observation.
Nothing happens quickly in D.C.
The fact that it was two days
later, he's like, "Good news.
We got your answer.
It's nothing,"
was very surprising to me.
But I also want to ask,
are you surprised, disappointed,
that Mueller did have these two
years and it seems as though,
you know, some people have used
the expression that he punted
on the decision whether or not
there was enough evidence
for obstruction.
Do you feel as though
an investigator
who had that much time
and that much freedom
should have come
to a more concrete answer
on that question?
-Well, but we don't know
what Mueller said because
we've not seen the report,
and that's part of the issue.
The American public
and certainly
the United States Congress
should have the ability
to judge for itself
what the evidence was,
what was the underlying evidence
that supported the report,
and there should be no hesitancy
by this administration,
certainly this Attorney General,
in giving it to us.
It is a matter
of serious concern.
[ Applause ]
And then we'll see.
You know, I think that
there's every reason to believe,
based on his entire career,
that Bob Mueller was thorough,
that he went
where the evidence took him.
But we need to see it,
because the other thing
I know as a prosecutor is that
there is a difference between
knowing what happened and being
able to prove what happened.
It doesn't mean
there's no evidence,
but it probably means that there
was not sufficient evidence
to maybe
bring certain charges.
But let's not also forget,
there have been 33 indictments.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Let's not forget
that there is a whole lot
of evidence of crimes
that have happened,
and people are taking
a toothbrush
to the courtroom these days
because of it.
-Are you shocked as a prosecutor
how quickly it does seem like
you have to remind people
how many people
who were close to
or worked explicitly
for the Trump administration
are either in prison
or have been arrested?
-I mean, I think that it is --
-If I had asked you
this question four years ago
and said, "There will be
somebody in office and they'll
have this many people connected
to them in jail..."
-It is quite unbelievable.
-Yeah. Right?
Okay, good.
-You're right.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, good.
'Cause I thought I was crazy.
-No, no.
And, actually, that's the thing
is that we all have to remember
that we are not crazy.
-Yeah.
-And that these are serious,
serious matters.